I don't know if I can rem recommend Nick
Fuentes. Why? I I don't know if I can.
Why? He's a brilliant young man. When I
say young, because I know he's younger
than me, right? Let me just comment on
why I have a problem with Nick Fuentes,
who's going to be watching me and he's
going to be throwing fombs at me because
I hear he watches me and cusses me out.
Why do I have a problem with Nick
Fuentes? You ready? Nick Fuentes,
brilliant young man, very well educated.
The problem is
From what I see, he's too extreme in his
view
in regards to the Jews. This is why
people
people accuse him of being a neo-Nazi
because he thinks it's a badge of honor
to want to question the numbers of Jews
who were killed in the Holocaust.
Because of his extreme views, he does
himself more damage than good. He's his
worst enemy and he gets himself in
trouble
and closes doors that otherwise would be
open if he wasn't extreme.
This is why we have to be balanced.
We don't become extreme right or left.
Let us say the 6 million Jews who were
there weren't 6 million. Let's say it
was 5,999,999.
Why make it an issue? Why
would you even want to bring it up? What
What do you gain
by questioning the numbers?
Why would you then join
Kanye West
on Alex Jones show
where he praises Hitler? Why?
So you need to discredit the Jews by
trying to make the number of Jews who
are slaughtered less than they are.
Really?
Okay. So let's say it's 1 million.
Why make it an issue? Whether it's 1
million, 2 million, 3 million, 4
million, why make it an issue? What do
you gain by it? Oh, we want to expose
the lies of the Jews. All right.
Wise as serpents, harmless as doves.
To the Jew, I became a Jew. To the one
with the law, I became like one under
the law. To the one without law, I
became as without law. I became all
things to all men that I may win some to
Christ. Isn't that Paul's attitude? 1
Corinthians 9.
1 Corinthians 9:es
19 to 23. 1 Corinthians 10:31-33.
Isn't that what Paul said?
Why make it an issue? Cause then Jews to
stumble and hate you and your faith
because you're speaking as a Catholic.
You're not speaking
on behalf of yourself. You're speaking
as a member of the Catholic Church and
they associate you with the Catholic
Church. What do you gain by trying to
make the numbers less? Do you think Paul
would have made that an issue?
So, if you're not about winning souls
and bringing them to the kingdom, then
disassociate yourself from the Catholic
Church. Say, "I'm not speaking as a
Catholic. I'm not a Catholic. I'm a
political analyst." But you talk and you
bark that you're a Catholic
and then you bring the Catholic Church
down with you because of your attitude.
Okay. So here, let's see what Paul would
do.
A definitely it ain't what Nick Fuentes
is doing.
So you think Paul was living today and
he would make it an issue about the
numbers of Jews that were slaughtered.
One Jew slaughtered is one too many. One
life slaughtered is one too many.
Right?
Isn't that true?
Isn't that true? Here. This is why as
much as I think he's brilliant and I
would wouldn't mind joining, I can't
because he does stuff that are so stupid
and unnecessary. Like when he joined
Kanye West, what was Kanye West wearing?
That black outfit that looked like a
condom that he was wearing a condom.
Talking about Hitler had some great
ideas. Seriously,
it's like saying Muhammad had some great
ideas.
Here
it is, black and white. You guys
remember that clip.
He's representing the Catholic Church to
make it an issue whether they cooked up
the numbers of the Holocaust.
What does that get you except backlash
not just from Jews, from others,
and then they hate you and your church
because of you?
Do you got you remember that, right? I'm
not lying. You saw that clip. And here
here's what Paul says. For though I am
free, 1 Corinthians 9:1 19 and 23 from
all, I have made myself a slave to all
so that I may win more. See, I became a
slave to everyone. What Paul is saying
is not that I compromise the truth. The
truth of the gospel, I will never
compromise. I will never water down the
gospel. I'll never deny who Jesus is.
But when it comes to other issues that
have no significance and meaning, when
it comes to a person's salvation, those
issues mean nothing to me. Whether it's
6 million or 5 million, how does that
affect one's salvation? Let's say it's 5
million, but I think it's 6 million. Is
that going to jeopardize my salvation?
You understand?
If I'm wrong about the numbers, will I
go to hell?
What does that got to do with winning
the Jews to Jesus Christ?
What does that got to do with removing
every unnecessary obstacle
that hinders the Jews from knowing their
God and Savior has become flesh? the man
Christ Jesus. In point of fact, when you
speak this way, you then remind the Jews
of their experience in medieval Europe
where to this day they say the Catholic
Church came up to us and said, "Kiss the
cross or the sword will kiss you."
They still haven't forgotten.
They still haven't forgotten the way the
Jews were treated in medieval Europe. In
point of fact, go to one for Israel,
that YouTube channel, One for Israel,
they have testimonies of Jews, even
rabbis, who thought Jesus was a gentile
god
because the Catholic Church came in the
name of their God, Jesus, to slaughter
them. That's how they identify Jesus
with the Catholics in Europe
slaughtering them. Not saying they're
right, but that's their perception. And
they thought this it was this God Jesus
who hated the Jews, who used his people
to slaughter the Jews. And then they
find out, no, Jesus was a Jew. His
followers were Jews. I'm not lying.
There's testimonies for Israel. Like,
man, I was shocked.
You hear me there?
So when you come as a Catholic voice and
downplay the atrocities that the Jews
have experienced,
all you're doing is fueling their hatred
of the Catholic Church. Because what
they're taught is this is what the
Catholic Church did to us in medieval
Europe.
They slaughtered our men and women and
forced us to get baptized,
losing our identity.
You get you get my point?
Yeah. Get rid of the trolls. So, let's
finish this here
right here. Let's finish it. For though
I am free from all, I've made myself a
slave to all so I may win more. Now,
watch Nick Fuentes justify this. This is
why there is no use talking to. In fact,
Candace Owens did you the courtesy of
bringing you on her channel. And she
even said, "What you like to do is you
go on your platform and start cussing
people out. You did it. You were kissing
Candace's aspirations, being nice, and
then right afterwards, you went on your
stream and you dropped fbombs and you
called people
That's what he did. That's what he does.
He acts brace you. F you. F you.
What happened, Nick? For though I am
free from all, I've made myself a slave
to all so that I may win more. And to
the Jews, I became as a Jew so that I
win Jews. You think Nick knows Paul? You
think he even follows the teaching of
Paul? To the Jew, I became a Jew. Nick
is becoming a Nazi to the Jew.
You see it right there?
Yeah. He does that all the time.
Right here.
Is he imitating the spirit of Paul? Paul
said to the Jew, "I became a Jew."
The guy's becoming a Nazi to the Jew.
That's why they call him neo-Nazi. In
fact, I got a comment because I was
playing Nick Fuentes. The guy called me
a neo-Nazi. See, guilt by association.
Guilt by association
to those under the law as under the law,
though not being myself under the law.
So that I might win those who are under
the law. To those who are without law as
without law, though not being without
the law of God, but under the law of
Christ, so that I might win those who
are without law. Now watch what he's
going to say in 1 Corinthians 10. To the
weak I became weak that I might win the
weak. I become all things to all men so
that I may by all means save some. So I
do all the things for the sake of the
gospel so that I may become a fellow
partaker of it. Now watch here. 1
Corinthians 10:31-33.
Watch here.
Whether then you eat or drink or
whatever you do, do all to the glory of
God. Don't do it for you. Do it for the
glory of God. Give no offense either to
the Jews.
You're telling me Nick is really
exemplifying the Catholic spirit?
following the spirit of Paul?
Give no offense to the Jews.
Give no offense either to Jews or to
Greeks or the church of God. You think
Nick is following Paul? You think if
Paul was here and he saw Nick, he would
be praising him? You are giving
unnecessary offense to the Jews as well
as Greeks, meaning the unbelievers the
way you speak or the church of God. And
you're also scandalizing and offending
the church.
See right there?
Now everything in perspective, in
balance. When you meet a troublemaker, a
rabble rouser, an enemy, then you put
them in their place. Rebuke them like
Paul did.
Everyone got this? Just as I also please
all men in all things, not seeking my
own prophet, but the prophet of many, so
that they may be saved. Wait, does that
sound like Nick? Does he please men or
himself and his cult followers who've
made him into an idol and they worship
him? Nick gives offense to everyone and
their mother, even those who are on his
side. He doesn't give a chance for
anyone to want to work with him.
Right?
This is what happens with social media.
You give platforms to young kids who
live in mommy's basement. They become
superstars and they attract a cult
following and they worship this cult
leader and he can do no wrong and it
emboldens them more and more. Yeah, but
they froze my accounts. And this is what
we call the martyrs complex.
Be careful of fake piety, fake
humbleness, fake humility, what's called
the martyrs complex,
where you think that because you're
being persecuted, that somehow justifies
your approach because after all, Jesus
got martyed for his cause because he
didn't tow the line. Therefore, I must
be right because they're trying to
martyr me. No, that is satanic. That's a
delusion. It's called the martyrs
complex.
You with me there?
You with me what I'm getting at? Be
careful of the martyrs complex. Not
everyone who gets his accounts frozen,
right, or deplatform is because they
were righteous and they were fighting
for the cause.
It's because of your extreme demonic
views where you alienate and demonize
and you arouse people to violence
because of your rhetoric.
That's why they see you as a danger.
Does it sound like he even knows the
faith? He knows what the church teaches.
He knows Paul. When Paul says, "Give no
offense either to Jews or to Greeks, and
I please all men," does that guy sound
like he knows Paul at all? So, as much
as I like him,
I I I just don't see myself being able
to share a stage with him because he's
too toxic. He thinks he's doing mankind
a favor and God a favor, right? Because
he thinks, look, I'm being
metaphorically crucified because, see, I
follow Jesus. I'm like Jesus. I I don't
pull punches. I'll say the fact no,
you're just an extremist lon
megalomaniac who has narcissistic
personality disorder. Right?